a new year is upon us are you ready to
make it your best language learning year
ever I certainly am thanks to my simple
six step yearly plan if you want to
learn how to crush it in 2023 and take
all your language goals to the next
level stay tuned because I'm going to
show you how I do it right now hi I'm
Lucan I'm a Language Coach who speaks 14
languages and on this channel I help
people learn foreign languages more
efficiently faster and in a fun way
so do you want to know how to crush your
2023 language goals let's Dive Right In
to make the most of the new year you
need to do two very important things one
reflect on your progress over the
previous 365 days and two plan your
learning for the next 365 days
this is very different from how people
traditionally go about setting their
goals at this point of the Year
typically people just set their New
Year's resolutions around what they like
to accomplish at the end of the year and
just go for it this plan requires a
little more thinking but it does a
better job of setting you up for Success
it encourages you to build upon your
last tier of learning experiences by
creating an action plan at the three
month one month and daily levels as a
result you'll always be aware of what
you should be working on and you will
always be able to stay on track but
enough Theory let's talk about the steps
of this plan so you can put it into
practice and crush 2023. the six steps
of the plan are as follows reflect on
your language learning progress over the
past year
assess your current language skills
visualize yourself one year from now
establish key goals and objectives for
the next three months
break down your key goals into daily
habits review and adjust your plan every
three months step one reflect on your
language learning progress over the past
year the first thing you must do is look
back on the previous year and think
about all that you've accomplished in
your language learning here it's useful
to ask yourself a number of guiding
questions including what went well in
the past year what did not go so well in
which areas did I improve the most in
which areas do I still need to improve
what were my biggest lessons learned
over the year
you don't need to be too rigid with
exactly how you go about this the goal
is simply to get a general idea of your
recent wins and losses so you can use
this information to create a more
optimized plan for the coming year for
example here's what I wrote when
reflecting on my Hungarian learning for
2022. I managed to learn Hungarian very
regularly throughout 2022 spending some
time with a language at least four or
five days each week also I modify my
practice activities to be mainly input
based as opposed to the output based
activities I'd been doing previously I
mainly prioritize listening to podcasts
and watching YouTube videos though I did
read the occasional book as well my
favorite podcast resource has been
Hungarian with sizzy 2022 was also a
great year for my Hungarian learning
because I had the chance to visit
Budapest and spend an entire month there
during the summer I've been to Budapest
before but this was the first time that
I really felt comfortable using the
language in everyday life I also had a
much easier time speaking with natives
than I've had in previous years and at
one point I even managed to have a
two-hour conversation with my tutor
Petra in terms of takeaways I can think
of three learning almost every day
really pays off
solid input skills are essential in
order to build solid output scales
traveling to the country where a
language is spoken can be a great reward
for hard work as well as a worthy
challenge that can spur future growth
you see creating a short but sweet
synopsis of the previous year's efforts
can help you gain a clear perspective on
what you have to do next
speaking of what you have to do next
let's move on to the second part of our
planning process
Step 2 assess your current language
skills when you're learning a language
what you're actually doing is developing
a network of interconnected skills in
your brain the four most prominent of
these skills are listening speaking
reading and writing to determine which
of the four skills you want to develop
in the coming year you should First Take
stock of your current abilities so you
can get a good idea of your strengths
and weaknesses as a learner this is
easier than it sounds all you have to do
for this step is think of a few things
you're capable of doing in each of the
major scale areas it may also be useful
to highlight what you currently cannot
do in these areas so that you know what
to work on next here's how I recently
evaluated my skills for Hungarian
reading I can read scripts of podcasts
aimed at B2 Learners and I've just begun
reading books aimed at native speakers
listen my ability to understand podcasts
and videos has improved drastically in
particular I'm most comfortable with the
podcast that both CZ and Petra produce
and I'm even managing to understand
YouTube videos on certain complex topics
I cannot understand news broadcasts yet
but my listening ability in general is
much improved over where it was one year
ago
speaking I can hold conversations on
most everyday topics without major
problems I still hesitate and make
mistakes of course but overall I feel
quite comfortable even during longer
conversations
writing I did not focus on building my
writing skills in 2022 so I cannot
really evaluate them at this point
however I plan to begin keeping a Daily
Journal in Hungarian starting in 2024.
not too bad right the point of this step
is to describe your language abilities
in concrete terms so that there's less
guesswork when it comes to the type of
practice you need to build into your new
learning plan
on to step number three
step three visualize yourself one year
from now
the last step was all about objectively
evaluating where your language abilities
are this next step is about emotionally
evaluating where you want your language
abilities to be one full year from now
why bring emotions into a learning plan
well your emotional state strongly
influences how motivated or unmotivated
you are to do something
if we can tie strong positive emotions
to your language goals then you'll be
much more likely to stick with them even
when the going gets tough
we can build this connection between our
emotions and our goals through creating
a visualization more specifically by
visualizing our future self after he or
she has accomplished all the goals that
we are about to set in this plan we can
build this connection between our
emotions and our goals through creating
a visualization more specifically by
visualizing our future self after we
have accomplished all the goals that
we're about to set in this plan I like
to treat this as a kind of meditative
exercise I close my eyes
and try to create a vivid mental picture
of myself at the end of the year doing
all the things I want to be able to do
in my target language
once I've created a sufficiently vivid
mental image I write it down so that I
can refer to it and expand upon it
through the year here's the end of the
year visualization I recently created
for Hungarian 31st of December 2023. I'm
in Budapest drinking a glass of palinkai
my friend's apartment we're having a
party and I'm speaking Hungarian with
the people there everyone I talked to is
amazed at how well I speak Hungarian wow
your pronunciation is incredible one
person says you're so fluent says
another I'm excited because I plan on
spending several months in Budapest in
2024 and it'll surely improve even more
by then the future is bright this kind
of visualization exercise may sound
corny at first but I can assure you that
the results can be quite powerful
especially when you keep the written
version handy and look at it whenever
you're tired stressed or otherwise
unmotivated to learn okay time for step
number four step four establish key
goals and objectives for the next three
months
the previous steps shouldn't have given
you a good idea of where you need and
want to improve your language skills by
the end of the year it's time now to
take those General ideas and boil them
down to concrete goals to things you
absolutely want to accomplish in the
next 90 days
why 90 days because that's how we're
going to take the whole year and make it
a bit more digestible instead of
thinking about all 365 days at once
we're primarily focused on 90 days at a
time which helps us remain focused in
the short and medium term so ask
yourself based upon your previous year's
learning your current level and your
visualization what you want to have
accomplished by the end of the next
three months your answer can be anything
so long as it leads you towards the
version of yourself you just pictured in
your visualization here are the language
goals that I want to accomplish about
the end of March 2023. I want to be able
to understand most podcasts aimed at
Learners especially cz's podcast even
the most difficult ones
I want to be able to understand YouTube
videos to a good 60 to 70 percent
without subtitles be it content for
Hungarian Learners or for Native
Hungarian speakers
I want to be able to understand at least
a good 60 to 70 percent of the news
without subtitles I want to be able to
greatly improve my reading skills
especially when it comes to reading
books be it non-fiction or novels I want
to improve my spoken fluency to a level
where I feel comfortable speaking both
with my teacher and Native Hungarian
speakers in general step five break down
your key goals into daily habits
goals are useful for providing a Finish
Line but do little to help you manage
the day-to-day work of language learning
you just created your three month goals
but the key now is to take those goals
and identify the daily actions that will
help you reach them these daily actions
will constitute your habits any habits
will suffice here so long as it consists
of something that if done daily will
realistically get you to your
three-month plan
in the last section I mentioned that I
want to be able to listen to a certain
level of podcasts to watch a certain
level of YouTube video without
difficulty and even watch the news
comfortably to do that I'll naturally
have to spend daily time consuming more
podcasts more videos and News until I
reach that level here's a list of a few
habits that come directly from the goals
I want to accomplish by the end of March
2023. I want to listen to at least one
episode of the Hungarian with sizzy
podcast every day and even take her
Course once it's available
I want to watch at least three YouTube
videos every week I want to watch the
Hungarian news for at least five minutes
a day I want to read at the very least
two or three pages of a book every week
I want to talk to my Hungarian tutor
Petra at least once a week and review
the lesson 24 hours later step 6 review
and adjust your plan every three months
the last step in our six step planning
sequence is actually a recurring one
every three months you should take out
your learning plan to review and revise
it Additionally you should revisit steps
four and five and come up with both
goals and habits for the next three
months
naturally since the year can be divided
up into four periods of 90 days you'll
have to come up with the four 90-day
plans before the year is done so keep
that in mind since it's only January and
this is something you'll have to do
regularly throughout the year I
recommend using a calendar or setting up
some kind of recurring reminder for you
to return to your plan every three
months and set up your new goals and
habits
all right those are the steps of my six
part annual language learning plan
sitting down every January to plan my
language learning like this has done
wonders for my ability to stay focused
and make serious progress in recent
years so I'm certain that it will create
powerful results for you as well let's
quickly recap the six steps of the
planning process reflect on your
language learning progress over the past
year
assess your current language skills
visualize yourself one year from now
establish key goals and objectives for
the next three months
break down your key goals into daily
habits
review and adjust your plan every three
months before we go I want to leave you
with one final tip once you write out
your yearly plan print it out decorate
it and leave it somewhere where you
always see it when you sit down to learn
this will serve you as a powerful
reminder of why you're learning and also
help you remember to review and revise
the plan as the year goes on if you'd
like to learn more about how I plan my
own language learning check the links in
the description box as I've left some
goodies for you there in any case thanks
for watching I wish you all the best as
you begin this new year and I sincerely
hope you'll be able to achieve all of
your language goals by Year's End
see you next time until then Happy
language learning